l'heure est à la fête pour la communauté
lgbt qu plus alors le festival fierté
montréal prend fin aujourd'hui avec le
traditionnel défilé de la fierté un bon
moment pour faire un bilan de ce 13e
festival mais aussi des défis auxquels
ont toujours fait face donc la
communauté en 2019 et pour en discuter
marie-eve baron qui est membre du
conseil d'administration de fierté
montréal merci beaucoup
y en a marre on d'être la merci des
mutations 13e édition quel bilan vous en
faites
ben mon dieu on a eu cette année encore
plus de visiteurs que prévu c'est encore
une fierté extraordinaire qu'on a cette
année on est vraiment contents de
recevoir tous ces gens de
l'international ça a été vraiment très
très très valorisant le défilé a lieu
aujourd'hui c'est notre événement
enfants vous le savez donc on attend à
300000 visiteurs 60 visiteurs on attend
3 5000 visiteurs et donc douze mille
marcheurs et les gens qui vont défiler
donc rené lévesque aujourd'hui aussi
qu'ils aient beaucoup de progrès qui ont
été faits évidemment lord et d'agrément
et lors des dernières décennies mais je
remarque également que vous recevons
encore en 2019 mais vous recevoir dans
vos réseaux sociaux des commentaires
sont un noeud de taff et puis même je
dirais qu on nous a affecté mon rien
dans nos vies observez qui avait plus de
commentaires haineux sur notre plate
forme de réseaux sociaux à nous mêmes
les autres organismes communautaires qui
vaut aussi dans la communauté diabétique
lui plus s'il est une chose dont qu il
ya comme une recrudescence peut-être
deux de ces fameux commentaires
l'oublier une augmentation de ces
commentaires haineux vraiment mais je
dirais dans les dernières années
ça a vraiment manqué qu'une montée de la
droite où je t'ai direction l'a fait
mais la dernière on exigera des ratés
décomplexée également probablement donc
on a une augmentation verdanson nos
plateformes
qu'est ce qui explique ce phénomène
selon l'oif de mal vous venez de le dire
c'est donc probablement la montée de la
droite ou peut-être aussi que les gens
derrière quand on est derrière l'aviron
sans peut-être un peu plus un peu plus
invulnérable donc on peut écrire tout ce
qu'on veut dévoiler des crimes haineux
également à ce qu'une augmentation des
crimes à mort fois parce que vous avez
remarqué c'est aussi sur le terrain
oui tout à fait il ya eu plus de
dénonciation des crimes homophobes aussi
à montréal du moins
puis voyez ce malheureux on aimerait ce
qu'en 2019 ça diminue au moins une photo
on regarde une fois toi ça
alors vraiment où vous la présenter
c'est le défilé de la fierté on la voit
d'ailleurs actuellement le défilé de la
fierté été rossé la et à venir à boston
alors ça ça va se passer à la fin où
l'extrême droite qui serait en arrière
de sa question pour vous est ce qu'il
s'agit de provocation incomplètement pu
même en fait je dirais que le choix de
la ville aussi a été stratégique de leur
part on sait qu avait le beau temps nous
donner une ville très ouverte la fierté
là bas c'est une grande fierté tu fais
partie du réseau des fiertés le réseau
interpride et fierté dans le monde
puis voilà donc et vous effectivement on
pense que c'est vraiment la provocation
d'aller à ce titre la communauté la
botte carrément jetée fmi en
contrepartie de l'autre côté hier je
sais pas si vous avez vu ces images on
voulait montrer également
oui mes joueurs de l'impact pourrait y
avait beaucoup des couleurs de la fierté
et même le numéro en arrière lors le vue
là si l'appareil est en arrêt en ciel
également vous allez voir donc le numéro
21 la marque et il ya d'ailleurs de but
alors la couleur de la fierté était là
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne chose surtout dans un milieu qu'on
dit marchons dans le sport on le sent
encore beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
mots phobie danlos profiter avant des
joueurs puis une équipe très populaire
très connu qui met de l'avant
cette inclusion le on est très très
content c'est justement c'est une grande
avancée
cela permettra plus d'athlètes encore de
faire leur coming out est plus à l'aise
parce que ce service en réseau interne
le sport donc raison qu'ils ont vraiment
besoin de notre support puis maintenant
on voit que à bagdad mouvement c'est
très très important
on espère qu'ils en avaient encore plus
dans vous avez travaillé ensemble ou si
l'impact qui vous a contacté où commence
le travail de cohésion qui s'est fait
depuis plusieurs années avec lui puis
maintenant on le fait le faux pas mal
pendant notre social donc ça donne
vraiment un levier encore plus grand
ouais vraiment et autres points
également il faut souligner françois
legault premier ministre du québec qui
sera là aujourd'hui il ya des absents
falls et un josh et notamment maxime
bernier mais françois legault y sera
c'est la première fois en vingt ans de
carrière qui participent à ce type
d'événement effectivement mais vient
aussi à titre de premier ministre
vous savez depuis en fait depuis les
années 90 avec la fondation d'art jean
marie yvette tous les politiques ont
toujours tous été invités peu importe
leur allégeance politique
donc aujourd'hui ça change pas que vous
savez dans le fond nous sommes dit flir
revendicateurs
on veut vraiment passer le message donc
on le pensait qu'il message aux élus qui
adapte les lois pour encore on a encore
beaucoup de revendications vous le savez
cette année on a dix revendications dont
par exemple pour ses simulations sur les
personnes intersexe on parle des
personnes trans migrantes ou départ en
transe comme moi qui ont réussi à faire
ou qui vont encore avoir des
revendications pour faire changer sertic
naissance de leur enfant par exemple
vous vous personnellement ce que vous
ressentez encore de la stigmatisation à
la société oui il y en a encore beaucoup
c'est sûr tout en échange ils y arrivent
toutes sortes de situations où on se
fait passer des commentaires on aimait
genre et comme personne 30
mais vous savez il sera beaucoup avancé
mais il reste encore du chemin à faire
donc on continue puis on le fait tout le
monde ensemble je pense que c'est un
message de l'inclusion d'un mot puis
aussi d'éducation faut éduquer les gens
autour de nous ah parce qu'on connaît
pas toutes les choses reconnaît fautrier
différence est important d'éduquer puis
je pense que c'est donc main dans la
main qu'on veut toujours marrant comment
des défilés va changer les mentalités
je pense que c'est en continuant d'être
présent en faisant de la diffusion aussi
évidemment les gens le voient et c'est
un mouvement social qui je dirais
internationale mène pas justice à
montréal avec des défilés à deux partout
dans le monde mettant presque partout
dans le monde voudrait mais c'est
quelque chose qui est qui qui vit change
la couleur de la société oui et vous
avez dit trois cent mille personnes est
ce qu'il s'agit d'une déchirure et les
plis plus grande allemand veut
participatif notre coin quand on est
fiers parce que c'est la plus grande
fille à fille de la francophonie donc
montréal on a vraiment une plateforme
vraiment acquis par exemple tout seul
évidemment les prénoms de grands
festivals de sur deux cette semaine donc
le nombre de 2.7 millions d'entrées
annuellement nos événements 250
événements
cette année donc c'est un très très
grand festival pour domaine des projets
pour l'avenir on veut obtenir une
licence pour organiser un one à montréal
en 2023 donc ce vote lors eu lieu en
fait juste le jour avant les élections
donc le 20 octobre on savoir si montréal
va tenir cette édition spéciale fut 1023
bon vous souhaite un très beau défilé
marié baron membre du conseil
d'administration affirme alain d'inertie
cette entrevue
merci beaucoup